同评产生共鸣，不同评激发思考。
欢迎你转到罗易威调评，收听我们以文化、工艺和时尚为起点发出的讨论。
大家好，我是洪晃。
今天我特别感谢罗易威品牌，
给了我一个机会对话复旦大学外文学院西班牙文的系主任，
西普与国家研究中心主任陈亦洋老师。
陈老师好。
晃姐好，大家好，我也很高兴这次有机会。
跟晃姐一起聊一下我们西班牙的奢侈品罗易威的历史，
包括跟西班牙的历史文化的关系。
陈老师，你知道我和我女儿都是罗易威的粉丝，
我们前几年就发现这个西班牙品牌真的是从传统工艺的细致到发挥，
当代创意都是特别棒的一个品牌。
他们今年180周年，
然后我去到店里头给小家伙要去买一个礼物的时候，
发现他们为这个180年做了一个180特级。
因为我觉得我们大家其实都知道罗易威这个品牌，
它已经在我觉得大部分人心目中都是一个非常历史悠久的奢侈品牌了，
但是可能不是所有人都知道它到今年就正好是180年了。
是的，我就不知道。
我觉得这个知识就是大部分人都不知道它有这么长的历史，还是挺不容易的。
对，我看了一下这个180特级，
我就对西班牙的文化历史就开始好奇，
因为我发现其实我真的不懂，
而且我有好多好多问题，
就是你像罗易威这个品牌，
他就跟其他的我们知道的名牌就非常非常不一样。
所以我也特别好奇，
就是说西班牙的文化西班牙的历史，
它在整个欧洲历史中它有哪些不同，
它又有哪些相同，
然后它的整个的发展是怎么过来的。
所以我就特别高兴今天给了我这么一个机会来给您聊天。
非常非常欢迎。
好的，你看别的像欧洲的这些老牌的奢侈品，
它都是谁谁谁就是有一个人的命名，
然后这个人就是创始人，
但是好像罗易威的创始是1846年在马德里。
是一批皮革将人一起成立的这么一个公司。
所以我就很好奇，
他为什么跟其他地方不一样，
那个时候1846年的话西班牙马德里，
它的经济上有什么特殊性，
就是让不是一个人或者一个家族去做这件事，
而是一些将人工匠联合起来创造一个工坊。
首先我觉得罗易威相对于欧洲其他的奢侈品牌，
他的创始年份要早很多，
就处于一个我们说钱资本主义经济时代吧，
然后西班牙相对于欧洲其他国家，
他这个经济的发展进程又相对慢一些，
所以他还处于一个就是农业社会到工业化社会的一个过渡阶段，
所以这些手工业将人吧，
他们还没有形成就是某一家能够垄断这个行业或者特别强大，
所以他们就需要一个像一个互助的这样一个集体，
大家一起来做一件事情，
然后到今天西班牙都是这样，
他包括那个牧羊人协会啊什么到今天都还在运行的。
我就想问就是当时的话，
1846年这个当时是一个匠人工作室，
是吧，就是一个皮革匠人共同组织，
为什么在马德里而不是在其他的地方？
就首先你要买比较好品质的东西，
你要有一个消费力，
虽然就19世纪后半年就巴塞罗那整个资本主义经济在蓬佩发展，
但是他跟马德里这种贵族啊王室啊这供庭消费的中心还是不一样的。
还有一点就是马德里在西班牙中部，
他就是有大批的那个牧业，
到今天马德里有个牧羊人节，
就那些牧羊人会赶着好多羊群穿过马德里市中心的，
我也有遇到过一次，
当时就惊呆了突然出现了这么多羊，
而且每年都会有。
那还是挺震撼的，
是是是到现在还有的，
你要有兴趣改天可以卡着那日子就去看，
然后所以他这个皮革供应，
而且他作为西班牙的首都嘛，
像原来摩尔人的在西班牙南部的，
比如说科尔多娃的这些手工匠人，
他的手工艺也有一部分等于就传到了马德里。
就一方面有这个物料的保障，
技术的保障，
有审美品味的，
有需要彰显自己社会阶层的人群在这里消费。
嗯，我明白了。
然后他们这次的话，
在庆祝180年的时候呢，
有一个红色的小狮子的形象，
说1872年的时候吧，
就有一个德国人叫恩里凯罗易威罗瑟伯格，
他加入了这个工坊，
然后他把他变成了以他自己命名的一个工坊，
所以就叫罗易威了。
然后罗易威在德文里头的意思是诗字的意思。
像这种样的事情说明西班牙当时的社会很开放啊，
他们并不是那么排外是吧？
他们不排外，
因为他们从历史上就不断的被外来的种族统治，
他们本身就是一个高度混血的民族，
历史上被罗马人统治过，
统治完了罗马人结束了希哥特人，
希哥特结束了穆斯林，
他刚把穆斯林赶走1492年，
他又开聘了美洲殖民地，
让美洲那些殖民地也不可能光西班牙人过去，
那边的人也会过来。
诶，我特别好奇您刚才说到，
因为他这里头也提到了一个摩尔文化，
我知道这个摩尔文化是和阿拉伯的文化是有关系的，
您刚才也说到，
就是西班牙是一直在被统治，
在被又解放，又统治又解放，
就这个过程当中，
阿拉伯人有没有在西班牙留下特别明显的痕迹，
或者是在他的文化中留下什么东西？
有很多，
比如说西班牙语里面叫阿达头的词，
它基本上就是词源是阿拉伯语，
然后呢，
比如说西班牙现在全西班牙每天访客量最高，
年度访客量最高的，
在格拉纳达的阿尔汉布拉公，
就完全是一座穆斯林宫殿。
阿拉伯人也是很好的牧民嘛，
然后西班牙原来的皮革中心，
就在南部的克尔多瓦。
克尔多瓦在十世纪的时候，
就是在穆斯林统治期间，
它是全欧洲最大的城市。
所以西班牙整个皮革业，
其实在一定程度上，
就是从摩尔人那儿继承下来的。
挺有意思的，
然后后来阿拉伯人的统治市，
从南部开始一直到马德里吗？
更北，到比利牛斯山。
真的是到了比利牛斯山啊？
那西班牙人，
果然他的文化精就应该跟比利牛斯山，
跟以北的不算太一样了，是吧？
是的，就是他的那种文化习惯啊，
包括他的绘画、艺术品啊，
我觉得在萊维的设计，
包括用色上面都能体现出来。
比如说他的Flamengo，
就福袋，
他其实就是西班牙不是有很多吉普赛人吗？
吉普赛人那个Flamengo舞，
那个舞群的群摆，
以这个为灵感，
设计了那个福袋宝，
所以他都是就曲线波浪型的。
哦，你知道我第一次认识罗伊威这个品牌，
就是因为这个包，
因为他这个包已经出了很多年了，
是的,
然后我妈妈是一个不买设置品的人，
他觉得这些东西都太贵，
但是他就是有一年在国贸，
路过这个，
因为他那个Flamengo包永远是红的，
那种红是很烈的那种红，
就很像西班牙的那个舞蹈，
那个Flamengo里头的那个裙子，
然后我妈妈就路过那个店的时候，
在厨窗里头看见这个包就走不动路了，
然后的话就说，
这包太好看了，
因为我妈妈从来不会对物质的东西，
有特别特别大的这种迷恋，
后来我说呀妈，
我给你买了吧，
我说这是我妈妈唯一一件设置品，
哇,
对,
很荣幸，
就是一个小红的Flamengo包，
是的,
我还有一个问题，
就是西班牙那个王室，
也不是像别的国家，
像英国那个王室就是继承下来了，
对吧,
法国的王室就被砍头了，
但是西班牙的王室好像实来实去是不是？
是的,
因为是这样，
其实西班牙就是之前历史上我们就不说了，
就王威继承站着，
因为哈普斯堡家族没有后裔了，
然后在欧洲引发了这个战争，
就哈普斯堡家族大战波旁家族，
最后波旁家族赢了，
1700年就波旁王朝驻驻西班牙，
然后到了20世纪就全球都是一个，
有去往史化，
要走入共和国这个趋势嘛，
西班牙也有，
那他共和国之后就开始，
共和国当然有一些保皇派势力呀，
保守势力呀，
就引发了内战，
西班牙内战还是一个很有世界影响力的事情，
然后1936到1939，
1939年结束以后就是，
他们那个Flang歌，
他是有强烈的王史情节，
他梦想中的西班牙要是一个王国，
就是对于罗易威这样一个品牌，
他是到1905年，
然后呢他被皇家命名为皇家御用的品牌，
在西班牙皇家御用这个他的地位还有吗？
还是有的，
我想起我读书的时候，
正好2004年我在西班牙，
然后现在的国王，
菲律沛六史是当时的太子嘛，
阿斯图利亚斯亲王，
他大婚，
然后就是电视全程直播嘛，
我们班有个同学，
就是他是一个附近的一个大的望族，
哇他们全家13个小孩，
都好激动啊，
一起要坐在客厅里一起，
全程看直播什么的。
所以他的王史的话，
在西班牙人的心里头，
还是一个非常有威望的这么一个地位，
那奢侈品的消费人群肯定也知道他的工艺啊，
还有所有的材料啊，
设计啊都应该是，
就王史要去御用就代表他是最好的？
是的,
而且他们是一个很认就是，
比如你百年老店啊，
就是有很多历史的东西，
他们会认，
而且西班牙人还有一点，
因为他们有很多old money嘛，
就是老钱嘛，
你去一个城市认识一个人，
你说啊我认识一个谁是谁，
人家就会问你他姓什么，
就是只要知道了他的父姓和母姓，
如果他是这个行业的，
比如望族或者大家就会比较认可，
我记得我在格兰娜娜工作的时候，
这个城市的牙医，
他们只认一个姓，
就这个姓市开的牙医证所，
大家都会很认可，
那我想像罗易威这个也是一个姓氏嘛，
他等于也是一个姓氏一个品牌留下来了，
又是王时认可的，
那在很多人的心中就是一种品质的保证。
嗯,
就是我看见他们这次在他2026春夏系列上，
老有一个小老鼠，
我本来想买的小老鼠，
但是后来我实在是不知道这个小老鼠什么意思，
销售说是因为在他们家档案时里头，
他们现在的设计师发现了一个小盒子，
说那个上头有个小老鼠，
然后那是什么小孩换牙的时候，
装那个小孩掉下来的牙齿的，
西班牙是有这么一个传统吗？
是的，牙纤，
他的牙纤是一只老鼠，
人家牙纤都是一个美丽的小女孩，
带着翅膀的来去牙，
他们家怎么是变成一只老鼠了？
对，一方面就是他文化里面，
天生就是比较轻轻动物，
还有一点就是原来西班牙，
其实这个伊比利亚半岛整个都是森林覆盖的，
所以他动物的多样性是很多的，
他又靠近北非，
就传说在公园史世纪的时候，
一只松鼠可以从直部罗陀海下，
一棵树一棵树跳，
不下树一直跳到比利尼尔斯山。
太好了，
然后就再不往北走了，是吧？
明白了，
就是他们现在的设计师叫Jack & Lazaro，
在他们的档案里头的话呢，
发现了这个作品之后就把它拿出来，
然后变成了很多特别有意思的产品，
比如说他做了一个包，
他是用玻璃做的，
然后他玻璃上头的包的那个part就是这个小老鼠，
然后灵感呢就是来自于他们在档案馆里头发现的。
这个小老鼠的小盒子，
然后这个玻璃包有各种各样的颜色，
西班牙是不是也有彩色布丽的工艺？
有,
它的色彩iPhone很丰富，
不仅玻璃，
还有陶瓷，
就西班牙有很多家装市场比较高端的磁砖，
包括中国市场上，
很大一部分都是西班牙的。
嗯，我们家在装修，
就好多人说啊，
你要想要这个你的书房高级一点，
你可以贴一些西班牙磁砖，
你看我们都已经说到了，
就是二十世纪初了，
然后到那个一九零五年的话，
黄石好像还是挺有势力的，
西班牙的内战是怎么发生的呀？
西班牙的内战就是一九三一年，
就是一批左派就选上去了，
他们就想淡化教会的势力啊，
然后进行经济改革啊，
那就肯定触发了原来的传统力量的不满，
然后就打起来了。
一九三六年弗朗哥带着他的北非军团，
就回到西班牙本土，
这批人是一直在轮战中的，
所向披靡就直接把这些共和派都打走了。
那那个内战的时候的话，
西班牙的那个皇族还是统治者对吗？
内战的时候已经不是了，
已经共和国了，
一九三一年，
就是说大选选完之后，
国王好像流亡了。
哦，那Franco后来统治的那几年，
他和欧洲其他的地方都是不一样的。
他统治的时候，
我老听别人说，
西班牙还是有点法西斯统治和宗教统治的感觉，
比如说在服装上头啊，
还有各种各样的就是娱乐方面的，
都是尤其是女性是非常受限制的对吧？
是的，就算的很保守嘛，天主教，
你也不能露啊，
就像现在西班牙都是无上庄海滩，
在那个时候是无法想象的。
还有就是西班牙天主教信仰不能离婚，
婚姻是你在上帝面前许下的承诺，
不能离婚不能墮胎，
孩子是上帝给你。
我看他们那个里头讲，
说在1945年的时候的话，
罗伊威的一个创意总监，
他叫 Jose Paz de Housas,。
他就在他的厨窗设计里头，
做了一套就是非常休闲，
但是又非常有趣味的，
有老鼠啊，有大老虎啊，
还有马车啊，
就是把这些比较有趣味的东西，
人对生活的嚮往就给表现出来，
然后因为当时45年还是翻扣的时候对吧？
对，他们就觉得，
比如说他们有一个厨窗是好像在一个渔船上，
有一个人拉着手风琴，
然后旁边摆的那些罗伊威的产品就很像，
他捕捉到的鱼，
然后有花，还有吃的什么的，
就是很快乐的那种生活。
对啊，就是生活很苦嘛，
就是好像也是对生活很苦的一种小小的抗议，是吗？
是，一直到1939年战后，一直到1950年代，
因为Franco 统治西方国家其实对西班牙等于是封锁嘛，
我也不清算你，
但是我也不跟你接触什么，
所以西班牙人一方面是宗教政治的压力很大，
另外一方面就是物质生活也比较苦，
但是1960年开始，
当时就美国好像就是要把Franco 拉入自己的北约这个阵营嘛，
就经济上对它启动了，
所以整个西班牙的经济就从1960年代起飞的。
你看，正好也就是1960年罗易威的话开始了他的服装系列，
1960年罗易威的成衣就应该是很有色彩的。
是，因为一方面西班牙天然的就是所有色彩饱和度比较高，
另外一点就是他的阳光特别强烈，
反而我体会很深的就是，
首先我在中国以前从来不防晒没问题，
在西班牙不防晒真的会晒伤，
还有一个就是眼睛就那个强光受不了，
一定要戴墨镜。
那这么强的光线下，
如果你的色彩饱和度不高，
在这样的阳光下照出来其实是比较惨淡的，
就像我们进摄影盆那个高爆光下面，
你就要装画的比较浓啊。
所以西班牙就是他是很喜欢那种浓烈的色彩表达的。
你看他1960年还有后来的话，
他当时就是在1965年的时候他们出这个成衣系列的话，
整个的主题就是海边休假。
因为一般要是去海边休假什么的话，
这种样的生活方式都是一个相对发达的工业生产社会才有的生活袭气吧。
是这样，就西班牙60年代打开国门之后，
第一个起飞的就旅游业。
哪怕今天你去西班牙那些海岛海岸，
你遇到大部分都是北欧的、英国、德国的。
我接触到一些他们可能从来没去过西班牙本土，
但是西班牙的海岛他们都去过了。
哦，西班牙的海岛还是有很多是很有名的。
你看就是我有的时候看好莱坞明星什么的，
新闻就是发生在西班牙的ibisa岛上。
对,ibisa是一个party的island。
我觉得中国的有好多时尚的人的梦想，
也是夏天去ibisa上头蹦地去。
所以西班牙到了60年代、70年代就已经开始开化一点了，对吧。
是的，就是他们看到了别的生活方式了。
他们在70年代出了一款包叫Amazona。
今年的话又被两名现任的设计师Jack and Lazaro。
复制成了Amazona 180来纪念它180周年的这么一个包包。
您看过Wonder Woman吧，叫神奇女侠。
就是在亚马逊的森林里头有那么一帮子神奇女人，
就是会打仗，会武功，会各种各样的。
就是这种样的传统和Amazona这种样的故事，
您知道是西班牙的神话故事吗？
因为亚马逊那个地区吧，就是现在我们传统上觉得都是巴西的。
其实有一部分就在原来，就葡萄牙的殖民地嘛当时，
就有一部分就在也在西属的，
比如说，比如他就很大的一块国土就在亚马逊森林里面，
我还去过，
所以我觉得就他和西班牙是一种很紧密的关系，
因为比如总统区在西班牙的历史上是非常重要的一块土地。
那亚马逊女战士这个形象可能在，
我相信在西班牙的文化或者历史记忆中都是存在的。
是这么来的。
所以在1975年Franco的统治结束以后的话，
也有一点就是说，
亚马逊的女战士在西班牙的文化中就可以重新呈现了。
女人的原来在Franco时代的束缚就结榜了，是吗？
是的，你可以是一个强大的女人，
不必是一个温顺的女人。
就是Franco不是培养了他那个继承人吗？
不然就换卡罗斯王子吧。
然后1975年Franco就去世了，
一去世他放心地把这个帝国交给他的继承人了。
但他没想到就是这个王子很聪明，
就在Franco活着的时候他表现得很归顺啊，
就是认同你的理念。
Franco一去世他就民主化改革，
民主过渡，更多女性上大学上班，
就是走出了传统的那个厨房吧。
所以Amazon这个包差不多就是同1975年推出的。
也就是换卡罗斯开始改革的时候，
Franco已经过世了才出来。
是的。
然后这么回事，
您看见那个包了吗？
看到了，很漂亮。
是吧。
然后我还看到王后也提着，
其实就是现在皇后来迪西亚成为皇后的之前，
已经受到了特别多的购物病，
这个女人离过婚。
而且就是所有西班牙人都觉得她很有侵略性，很强势。
但是现在大家也接受她吧？
对，大家觉得她还是做得挺好的吧？
就您想她是03年公布恋情，04年结婚，
到现在22年，
她就是很稳，很大女主，就扛得住，一波一波的质疑。
嗯,Amazonian woman, Wonder woman。
75年以后的话，
像罗伊威这样的老的西班牙的品牌，
她就会开始和欧洲其他的国家有很多接触了，
比如说她会去好像Karl Lagerfeld，老佛爷，
还有那个阿玛尼，
都在罗伊威做过成衣系列的设计。
所以就是她开放了以后的话，
她和欧洲比利牛斯三移北的，
是不是这些地方是不是联系就更多一点了？
是，就是其实她就整如融入了欧洲这个奢侈品的大家庭吧。
就大家会有很多互动和交流。
包括我看她最近出的一款，
因为我挺喜欢瑞士那个昂泡鞋的嘛。
我看罗伊威就跟那个昂泡合作就推出鞋子。
其实她在好莱坞，她也是挺有影响的。
她们跟有一个好莱坞的女演员叫Ava Gardner，
就关系特别好。
她也特别喜欢用罗伊威的包。
然后有些倒是请出乎我意料的，
Andy Warhol还好,。
但是有一个是一个街头画涂鸦的艺术家叫Kee Tharing。
他们从导案实力头发现的话，
就是跟罗伊威都是有关系的。
而且他们都是在经常参加罗伊威的活动了。
我觉得对我们来说，
西班牙是西方的，罗伊威是欧洲的品牌，
但在他们西方内部，欧美内部，
他们会觉得西班牙是一种意志存在，
就是跟其他的欧洲或者欧美又不是那么一样。
所以你看那个阿姆多拉她拍的电影，
不是得了好莱坞好多大奖吗？
她就是她一个西班牙的小村庄，
就你虽然也是我们欧洲的，也是我们西方的，
但是你跟我们又不一样，你的血统也不一样，
你的文化的构成也不一样，
包括就是Flanco那些年不是也等于跟西方断了联系几十年吗？
那他们对西班牙你到底在发生什么？
就各种复杂的情节吧？
让他们对西班牙会有一种特殊的关注。
所以尤其是你像从Ava Gardner，
好来乌明星到海明威这样的左翼作家，
到先锋艺术、波普艺术的这些人的话，
他们想通过罗伊威去了解更多的西班牙文化。
而且本身二十世纪最伟大的这个画家也都是西班牙的？
画家那就是更不要说了，
就是西班牙人的对艺术的感觉是非常厉害的。
你知道我去西班牙的时候，
他们告诉我一个情况就是西班牙的建筑是非常厉害的。
因为大家都知道有个普利斯克奖是建筑界的奥斯卡，
得奖最多的是西班牙人。
是的，从高低开始嘛，高低的建筑都非常有辨识度。
以至于我觉得巴塞罗娜在整个欧洲城市里都是独树一致的，
它的那些颜色、线条。
我觉得巴塞罗娜的城市的规划，
就像有好多好多Amazoner的包包一样的，
就一个方块一个方块的。
就这是十九世纪末的城市规划，
所以他们在城规或者建筑这方面还是很有前瞻性的。
是的，你知道我怎么特别喜欢上罗娜娜吗？
就是因为她上一任的创意总监叫Jonathan Anderson，
是一个爱尔兰人。
他就是您刚才提到的那个Puzzle包的设计师。
我也很喜欢他的设计，我是Puzzle包的粉丝。
是，我也是。
然后我看到就是说，他在设计这个Puzzle包的时候，
他说他的企图是想用几盒去解构一个包的结构，
然后让一个包的话在不用的时候，他能是平的。
这样的话，储藏起来就很方便，是。
而且他的包的形状也可以有一定程度的调整，
就是我觉得很挑战我们想象力，
你没有看到Puzzle包之前，
你从来没有想过一只包可以是这样的。
因为我觉得Jonathan Anderson这个人本身他就是很有那种英伦的那种幽默感的，
然后他就又在罗娜娜里头找到了很多罗娜娜的同去，
就把这两个放在一起，就真的是很了不起。
我觉得他对当代的罗娜娜建设的这个十年的话，
他在任的十年还是非常厉害的，
但他现在的这两个设计师也很厉害。
我发现他2026年的这一季的话，
他特别强调了西班牙的阳光，他的海滩和他的色彩。
您穿衣服是不是西班牙风格的，有很多色彩。
我是到西班牙就开始无缘六色。
您真是入乡随俗啊。
您觉得就是在罗娜娜的这些产品里头有没有哪一件对你来讲是代表罗娜娜的趣味的？
我很喜欢那个大象包，
因为你在设置品里其实是找不到一个动物主题的包的。
他没有这种包袱，他可以变得很好玩，我觉得他就很自由。
是，而且他每一款他的色系都很齐全。
这个必须的西班牙品牌必须无缘六色的。
陈老师，我想说一件事情，
我去过很多欧洲品牌的档案时，
我就发现他们对流档案这事儿超级的用心，
这是一种什么文化就是流档。
就是我觉得他们有这样一个档案保存，
并且历史记录的传统，
因为我现在就在做西班牙语的档案中的中国研究的项目，
你会发现从可能16世纪开始，
一直到19世纪的中国史都可以在西班牙的档案中找到故事不证，
要两方面写的拿出来印证，
然后我就发现他们一个是教会都会存档，
就梵蒂岗有大量的档案，
然后政府就西班牙王室，官方的机构，
甚至法院他有大量的档案，
包括西语的档案不仅在西班牙，
在比如说英国有些贵族，
甚至美国当时18几几年有一些贵族家庭，
他也很喜欢搜藏那些档案，
就发现研究中国的档案可以在欧洲、美国找到很多。
然后另外一方面研究阿拉伯语世界就是穆斯林历史的，
因为中东战乱很厉害，
所以他们研究中东历史的很多人都到西班牙去查档案。
您自己怎么留档案呢？
原来还熟悉，
就我的日记每年的那个工作手册都舍不得人，
现在慢慢的就家里负担，
实体负担太重实在没办法留，
我有的就扫描了，
然后存到电脑里，
然后上传到云里面。
所以我觉得在没有数码之前，
他们能够把档案留成这样是非常不容易的一件事，
我就是有了数码之后的话，
我现在在写一本书，
我就发现我的留档能力是非常低的，
我经常就是会有几个version的chapter one，
但是我到最后留了八个version，
我也忘了哪个是第一个，哪个是第八个了。
啊，这是不是在写书的是特别一个disaster是一个灾区？
也没有，就是可能每一个版本都有它的吸引力，
其实它体现了你在不同的时刻，
你可能对一个话题的思考和体会不一样。
是的，但是如果说我们好好留档案的话，
我们就记录了我们的一个观察，
记录了观点，也记录了我们的情绪是吧？
是，有些东西就翻出来，
你会觉得很有意思，
包括我自己看我中学时候的日记也会觉得很有意思。
陈老师，咱把这期节目如果说变成一个档案盒的话，
其实我们在这里头放了好多东西了，
西班牙上千年的历史都进去了，
我们想说的就是说西班牙其实它的文化变迁还是挺大的，
那作为罗易威这样一个品牌能够在这么大的社会和文化的脱变里头。
能够不仅成活下来，
而且到今天在全世界成为一个年轻人追捧的这么一个品牌的话，
说老实话，我女儿比我更是罗易威的粉，
你觉得她的活力是从哪来的？
我觉得西班牙的历史文化本身就是非常多样化的，
相对于欧洲其他的国家，
从种族到文化的构成，
到历史的变迁，
它的多样化丰富性，
那罗易威就是不断的在吸收表达，
所以他就是能够跟着历史不断的叠带，
在奢侈品里面可能是更契合年轻一代的这种自我表达的诉求，
既厚重又有活力。
对，他们品牌自己认为他们一直是以他们的公义作为他们最核心的部分，
他们要用他们的作品来记录这个社会的变迁，
西班牙文化的变迁，
我还有特别喜欢罗易威的一件事，就是罗易威的公义大奖，
这个我觉得是一个很伟大的举作，
因为我觉得首先罗易威的话，
他作为西班牙的品牌，
他对公义是有一种独特的解释角度的，
他的公义是多元化的，
而用罗易威的名字来做一个公义展的话，
就我觉得超级的来劲。
然后他2024年的时候，
他在上海举办了一个将义天地展览，
那个才是很震撼的，
因为他不仅包括了西班牙，
还包括了亚洲的将人，
是一个特别大的庆祝手工将人的一个庆典。
我觉得这还是挺感动的，
因为我们有的时候尽情的在享用这些奢侈品，
真的没有想到他背后有人是一针一线，
一点一滴的劳动的结晶积累下来，
才有我们手上、身上这些非常舒适又奢华又漂亮的物质，
来表达我们自己对生活的感觉。
其实就是他既滋养了这些可能会消失的公义，
供给了给了他们一个舞台或者是一点资助这些公义，
然后另外一方面这些工匠和工艺也可以反部落一地，
给他新的灵感不同的设计可能性，
就是彼此滋养一起拓展生命维度的这种感觉吧。
是的，所以罗伊威我觉得是一个非常不容易的与时共静的，
然后工匠精神特别强大的一个品牌。
是，所以他1975年推出了Amazona，
26年又可以推出一个不同的Amazona 180，
就是既有传统又有创新。
嗯，好的陈老师，
谢谢你给我解释这么多关于西班牙的事情。
谢谢晃姐，很高兴，我也是。